hello everyone let's talk about
potential energy potential energy is
energy that is stored in an object and
this energy is related to the potential
or the future possibility for an object
to have a different type of energy like
kinetic energy from motion that is
converted from that potential energy
there are many kinds of potential energy
but they all arise from an object's
relation to a position or an original
shape
so while in general there are many
different types of potential energy
there are several specific types that
are very common so let's talk about
these
gravitational potential energy is the
potential energy that an object with
mass has due to the force of gravity
from another object with mass like say
the earth
and in fact we often use the surface of
the earth to compare an object's
position with to see how much potential
energy it has in the earth's
gravitational field
gravity is an attractive force so
objects with mass want to move towards
the surface of the earth if we move them
further away or opposite the direction
of the gravitational force we increase
their gravitational potential energy and
the opposite is true if it gets closer
when an object is on the surface of
earth we typically say it has no
potential energy but you could use any
point to be this comparison where
potential energy is zero
consider a book on a bookshelf if the
book is on this shelf we can use this
shelf as the 0.4 potential energy moving
it to a higher shelf would mean it has
gravitational potential energy relative
to that lower shelf
or relative to the floor if we want to
use that as our comparison instead
next we have elastic potential energy
which is the potential energy some
objects have due to their shape being
changed these types of objects are
called elastic objects
elastic objects are made of materials
and designed so they have internal or
inside forces that try to return them to
their original shape
one very common example of this is a
spring when you stretch or compress a
spring you change its shape and the
shape of the spring causes internal
forces that try to return the spring to
its original shape
now electric potential energy which is
the potential energy a charged object
has due to the electric force from
another charged object
opposite electric charges are attracted
to one another and similar electric
charges are repelled so the potential
energy depends on what type of charges
there are and how far apart they are
potential energy increases when the
charges move opposite the direction of
the electric force for example when two
negative charges get closer together
similarly magnetic potential energy is
the potential energy a magnetic object
has due to the magnetic force from
another magnet
magnetic force causes similar poles to
repel one another and opposite poles to
attract and because magnets have north
and south poles the potential energy
depends not only on the position within
a field but also the magnet's
orientation
again you could increase the potential
energy by moving the magnets opposite
the direction of the magnetic force for
example by pulling apart a north pole
and a south pole
all of these types of energy are due to
different forces and are calculated
differently from different equations
which we won't cover here but they are
all potential energy and these are just
a few of the most common types of
potential energy but there are more
in summary potential energy is the
stored energy in an object due to its
position its properties and the forces
acting on it
potential energy is measured relative to
some comparison position or shape and
describes the potential for other forms
of energy commonly kinetic energy from
motion to exist
there are many forms of potential energy
including gravitational elastic magnetic
and electric thanks for watching and i
hope you learned a little bit of
something